[Music]  there were dragons when I was a boy  where they went  only a few know our story changed the  world forever  we did it  the world's first dragon Viking utopia  Julia don't be on maybe Mike's less  Claire did it more Oh Santa honey  hey buddy wait up  oh my god he's not the only one she's a  light fury yeah oh sorry did he just  disappear  [Music]  Wow  it's a hidden dragon worth  toothless go introduce yourself  [Music]  toothless has a girlfriend I've hunted  every Night Fury except yours  hand him over I will never give him up  then I will destroy everything you love  we are no longer safe here we all have  to disappear completely off the map we  have to fight for their freedom  [Applause]  [Music]  you don't nothing allowed you a dragger  [Music]  show them what you got  [Music]  save him  as you and me bud Oh  [Music]  [Music]